hello fellow Guardians I'm John Luke I'm
joined by Jay what's up clans
clans are up the clan servers are now
available in-game for destiny so you can
go join a clan and you are probably
wondering why yes join a clan in destiny
one clans were just kind of a system to
like gather your friends but they didn't
really do anything right so like destiny
- it seems like the clan system is a
much bigger deal so kind of tell me why
I should join a clan or why okay well
I'm fine so you hit a menu here and we
go there is a full-on clan menu now
Austin's the official GameSpot clan as
you can see with this hot banner made by
Rob shout out to Rob and as you can see
here there is a season one they have
multiple seasons they're gonna be doing
I don't know how often they change but
essentially you can level up your clan
per season and that is going to get us
different bonuses so there is a certain
amount that the clan as a total can get
XP to level up and then there's your own
personal one and then there is stuff
every week that you can check off doing
things like the crucible nightfall raid
and trials which you all need to have a
certain number of members and the clan
to do so about half which is pretty easy
I mean you think of like a nightfall you
just need to have like one other person
basically to do that kind of stuff but
the advantage of all this is it all
builds up to the score and then on your
character you have this clan banner that
you can go get from Hawthorne and it
will give you all these really cool
perks so you can get additional glimmer
you can get increased public event
rewards improve rewards from cabal there
is increased reputation tokens for doing
night falls and raids and trials which
is pretty rad and that's awesome and
then you increase your chance of
receiving an Engram when doing any
playlist activities with the clan member
which is pretty rad so basically just
more ways to get the sweet loot that we
want already and it's like why why not
at this point right like you should
basically join a clan just to get these
perks because you're missing out
essentially right and it
I mean so there are obviously the
advantages
like these ones you're getting bonus
stuff by playing with people but even
then like as long just doing things get
you a personal contribution so as long
as you're in a clan that has a lot of
levels
you still get these extra benefits yeah
exactly like art and in terms of the
personal contributions I've got them
from doing you know just as mentioned
before like some of those public events
I've got them from doing patrols so
there's various ways to contribute to
the clan and every time you do do so it
shows up on your screen like oh cool
like I just did 250 personal
contribution of the clan or like you see
when somebody else level the clan and
it's pretty cool it's just like you guys
have like this XP bar that you guys are
all working to and you're like cool
level two we get more like yeah and then
so clans are not related to a specific
console they're actually just as like a
whole there they're tied in through the
like bungie.net and stuff and over here
you would actually be able to see
everyone this part seems to be a little
buggy it is the launch date yeah say one
of clans so it's not totally shocking I
mean considering it took them like what
like three days now just to get the
clans up because they weren't up so
definitely a work in progress but still
cool to see it in the game yeah and it
already
we haven't even like actually like sat
down and done some like proper like
grouping up over already starting to get
our rank up which is pretty rad so yeah
I think there's just no there's honestly
no reason to just not join a clan there
so if you go to bungie.net
and you try and join one there some
plans to have to be invited only for
example ours you can request an invite
but we have to accept it mm-hm
because there's only a list of a hundred
people so at the moment we're not we're
being a little picky but yeah we're just
making sure most of our office are in
and some of our like close friends that
were maybe formerly in clans with us
before that we play a lot with we're
trying to get those people in but of
course once we kind of fill that out
we're hoping to also try to add some
some of the community exactly but if
you're just interested in joining any
clan just to get reward so there are
plenty of clans that probably have just
an open invite when you're searching
it'll let you know it's open and you
could just join it if you just need a
place to join a clan so ya go
a clan and get yourself some sweet sweet
extra loot cool thanks Jonathan so there
you go everybody that is how clans work
in destiny - if you want to see even
more destiny coverage check us out we
have really awesome videos on class
guides how to get certain exotics and
how to do all those sweet heroic public
events which you want to do with your
clan thanks for watching